the nfl's concussion litigation the
massive class action that ultimately
included
all retired players it was settled
preliminarily in
august of 2013. it took a while for it
to become approved eventually the nfl
had to agree to remove all limits all
caps
there's no set fund from which benefits
are paid
if someone qualifies they get the
benefits an issue emerged in recent
months
regarding the process for getting
benefits based upon cognitive impairment
a lawsuit was filed several months ago
alleging that the entire settlement was
tainted by the practice known as
race norming and in a nutshell here's
what it is yeah
because what you're ultimately doing
when you show cognitive impairment
is showing a reduction in cognitive
capacity
below some set pre-existing baseline
and the farther you drop below the
baseline
the more eligible you are to receive
benefits under the settlement
under the process known as race snoring
which was not unique to the nfl
yeah this was something that was part of
the broader psychiatric and cognitive
evaluation process black americans
had a lower baseline they were presumed
to have a lower cognitive
capacity regardless of any head trauma
so what that does in this context
it makes it harder to prove impairment
because the white players
have a higher level wherever you are now
yeah you're starting from a lower spot
so it's harder to show impairment if
you're starting higher oh we got more
impairment
if you're starting lower we got less
impairment and
the lawsuit that was filed was dismissed
but
to their credit thank you nfl yeah has
decided
to scrap that process all together and
go back
and reopen all the claims that were
evaluated
based upon race norming and redo it
with a different standard a different
process that's going to result in
greater benefits being pla
paid to players are either were denied
or got less than what they
should have gotten and uh yeah i i
sensed this was coming yesterday when
the lawyer who represents all of these
retired players came out and said i was
wrong
yeah i never should have allowed this
right the nfl within hours after that
said
you know what let's let's let's just
start over again and and
kudos to everyone involved for doing the
right thing yeah it's the right thing
there's no doubt about it i mean it just
was a bad look all together on a human
perspective and like
it looked you know very convenient that
that was the rules set forth there for a
league that's 70
or more black as far as the cash i don't
think i don't
think that was what it was about i'd
like to think
that it wasn't deliberate i know i'd
like to think that the nfl didn't say
hmm right um i i think that
i think that that practice is so deeply
embedded
into our society industry yeah right
into the into the
the folks who are entrusted with making
these determinations
that it just kind of trickled in and
nobody spotted it that that's
that's that's what i hope you're right i
think yeah and
regardless regardless it's gone now yeah
and and uh it's gonna work to the
benefit of plenty of guys
who already now the problem is they've
already had to wait this long which is
unfortunate they're going to have to
wait even longer
and and that's you know the problem with
removing the cap and i was concerned
about removing the cap
because that created a very real
incentive
to to fight and fight and fight these
claims because there's no cap
if there's a cap hey you know we're
eventually going to run out of money in
this fund but why are we going to fight
these claims tooth and nail
there's been an incentive to fight these
claims harder and they've been stories
that have come out
over the years that you know guys guys
have had a hard time
getting what they're entitled to because
uh the the process
the defense against these claims has
been aggressive but one big element
has now it's great evaporating let it go
back
and they're gonna look at these claims
again and better late than never
uh but it would have been better
obviously if that never had been used in
the first place
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports